as a third member of the white house
inner circle tested positive for the
coronavirus
cbs news has learned the personal
assistant to ivanka trump has contracted
the virus
joining a valet to the president and the
spokesperson for the vice president
there are now more than 1.2 million
known infections
in the united states this says the
punishing effects of the virus and its
impact on the economy
have led to the highest unemployment
rate in the u.s
since the great depression michael
george is on wall street
this morning with more michael good
morning
good morning dana the stock market ended
the week regaining more than half its
losses from the past few weeks but
there's a big disconnect between wall
street and main street
29 million americans are now out of work
as the country begins the slow process
of reopening
staying at home for a month over a month
it was really nice to come back
just in time for mother's day california
florists are among the few permitted to
be open for business
with curbside pickup we've all worked
together for a long time
but many americans face longer term
unemployment
hardest hit hospitality and travel 7.7
million jobs
lost in april alone retail lost more
than 2 million
manufacturing and health care more than
a million each
all the sudden we have nothing fabian de
acostini a father of two
lost his job as a server at a florida
hotel we don't know
when we're gonna go back to work and
if all of us will be back minority
workers are especially hard hit
the black unemployment rate is now 16.7
percent
and 18.9 percent among latinos there's
no one other than the food bank and
situations like this you know to help us
out in hawaii where shawn hashimoto
father of three
lost his job food lines are now
essential
but the question looming even for
businesses that have reopened
will patrons return i think more
people's gonna get sick
because people are gonna get crazy
they're not gonna follow
you know the instruction i don't think
we're ready to open yet
in the midwest as workers returned to
tyson's waterloo iowa meat plant
following an outbreak this week
the next day health officials reported
more than a thousand plant workers
tested positive
this is one link between your farm and
your table
small farm to table operations are
booming while large processors
struggle lauren berry picks packs and
ships directly to homes
allowing people to skip stores and large
processors
another indication the coronavirus is
shifting business as usual
and in a new york nursing home there's
now a touching
no touch reunion through the glass we
thought why can't we bring our families
to us
create this tent make a comfortable area
set it up so that the families they
could see each other and really bring
that emotional piece back to them
a phone line that allows loved ones to
say what needs to be said
i love you very much
and as we see signs of hope there is
still a terrible human cost to this
crisis
today the number of americans killed by
the coronavirus topped
77 thousand jeff all right michael thank
you
very much as mentioned earlier
unemployment numbers for the month of
april